In this video, we'll examine how various DCC applications handle scene hierarchies
and how best to preserve them in Unreal Engine.
As we've already seen, Datasmith creates a hierarchy of parent and child relationships
in Unreal Engine to mirror a similar setup that started in the DCC tool.
Whenever possible, consider adopting various naming conventions and using tools in your
DCC application to automate hierarchies and keep things organized.
Consider using layers, groups, blocks, adjusting your pivot points, or using dummy or null
objects which are quite similar to empty actors in Unreal Engine.
Let's start with 3ds Max.
Consider using the layers tool which works exactly the same way in Unreal Engine as it
does in 3ds Max.
All objects in each layer will be preserved when it comes over into Unreal.
If you'd like to preserve the parent-child-actor relationship in the Outliner, if you'd like
to preserve a parent-child-actor relationship in the Unreal Engine Outliner, use the group
tool in 3ds Max to provide an empty actor for the child meshes to be attached to.
Ensure the pivot points are in the correct place and liberally use the rename tool to
ensure you know what each object is.
Be careful exporting any objects in 3ds Max that have been scaled or mirrored.
If you have, use the reset XForm tool in the Utilities menu prior to exporting.
Also note instances are preserved from 3ds Max and will result in a single static mesh
over in Unreal Engine 5.
Here in Sketchup Pro, we can already see an example of when it can be important to rename
your actors to ensure that you know what they are.
If we didn't know what these are over in Sketchup, we're certainly not going to know
what they are when they translate over to Unreal Engine.
The way the hierarchies work is a group is used as a top parent under the Data Smith
scene, then come the components, then come the various objects that are part of the component.
If an object is separate and not part of a component or a group, it will lie directly
under the Data Smith scene in the hierarchy.
Be sure to name your objects, components, and groups according to a naming convention
that works for you.
Otherwise, as we can see, things get very messy very quickly.
Like 3ds Max, components that have the same definition will become instanced in Unreal
Engine 5 and only have a single static mesh definition per object.
And again, like 3ds Max, layers will be preserved, which is primarily helpful for selecting groups
of actors at once and toggling on and off different categories of objects.
In Revit, the hierarchy works like this.
A level is used as a top parent under the Data Smith scene, then come the family types,
then come the components inside of that family.
The layer list that Unreal Engine will give you after a Revit file will be based on family
types.
Note that because of the nature of Revit, you'll be somewhat more limited in terms of how you
can rename or rearrange different assets.
Note that families also count as instance geometry and will create one mesh in Unreal
Engine that gets used by all family objects in the scene.
Note that a family will create a single static mesh in Unreal Engine, which then becomes instanced
throughout the scene, just like 3ds Max and SketchUp Pro.
For Rhino, our layers become the top parent in UE5, then the defined blocks, then the
various components of that block.
Note that Rhino groups do not affect the hierarchy in UE5, unlike 3ds Max.
In Rhino, we recommend using blocks as much as possible, as they'll also help with establishing
pivot points.
Otherwise, the pivot point of every object will be set to 000, resulting in objects that
are very far away from their origin.
Again, be sure to rename layers and individual objects in Rhino so when they come to Unreal
Engine they still make sense.
And note there's a robust scripting community for Rhino, and there are scripts out there
that will rename objects based on layers, groups, or anything else you might like.
Here are two Python scripts as examples.
Note that instanced blocks in Rhino result in a single static mesh definition for the
components of that block, again carrying on this trend that one piece of geometry can
then be instanced many times when it makes its way back over to Unreal.
In the next video, we'll explore the modeling tools available to us in Unreal Engine.